au commencement de l'automne de l'année
1826 la baby roto principal personnage
de cette histoire fut surpris par une
averse en revenant de la maison où il
était allé passer la soirée il
traversait donc aussi promptement que
son embonpoint pouvait le lui permettre
la petite place déserte nommée le
cloître qui se trouve derrière le chevet
de Saint-Gatien à Tours voici donc le
début du curé de tour roman écrit en
1832 par Honoré Balzac ici c'est
évidemment la cathédrale Saint-Gatien
qui sert l'intrigue mais tour il a
Touraine sont très présents dans toute
l'oeuvre de Balzac du Lys dans la vallée
au Père Goriot en passant par Maître
Cornélius car Balzac est né ici à Tours
en 1799 et c'est l'universitaire Aline
murale qui nous emmène maintenant sur
les traces de l'enfance de nouée de
Balzac
[Musique]
bonjour Aline Murat Brunel on dit d'ici
donc en plein cœur de Tours rue
Nationale ou née le 20 mai 1799 le petit
honoré qui est le premier fils en tout
cas de Bernard François balsa alors il
est issu d'une famille paysanne du Tarn
mais très vite il est venu à Paris où il
a été administrateur au conseil de Louis
XVI et il est venu par à Tours un peu
par hasard parce qu'il a été nommé comme
administrateur de vivre de la 22e
division militaire de Tours ainsi qu'à
ses soeurs du juge de paix la maman
alors Anne-Charlotte Loire salambier
j'ai l'impression que ce n'est pas une
mère aimante non c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est Anne-Charlotte leur
Salembier était issu d'une famille de
bourgeois de commerçants de Paris du
Marais et elle n'avait que 18 ans à
peine 19 ans lorsqu'elle s'est mariée
avec symptômes de 51 ans et disons que
la naissance de ce fils qui ne lui
ressemblait guère ne lui a pas apporté
que des joies et très vite elle a décidé
de le placer en nourrice de l'autre côté
de ce pont que Balzac admirera à temps
un des plus beaux monuments de
l'architecture français dit-il dans le
curé tout à Saint-Cyr donc chez une
nourrice il n'y est revenu que à trois
ans et demi en 1803
[Musique]
alors on a quitté la rue Nationale on
est à quelques dizaines de mètres
centaines de mètres maximum et on arrive
à la pension gay alors c'est en fait la
première pension école du petit honoré
oui absolument c'est là qu'il venait
accompagner par un valet matin et soir
il était externe à partir de l'âge de à
peine 4 ans et il est resté jusqu'en
1807 et c'était éloignement finalement
il se poursuit ensuite après la pension
gay on l'envoie à Vendôme le pauvre
petit honoré oui oui absolument et avant
d’eau mais il était au collège des
oratauriens bon c'était le vœu de son
père parce que c'était un collège d'un
bon niveau mais il est resté là-bas six
ans jusqu'en 1813 c'est 14 ans il était
extrêmement
malheureux abandonné mais il a cultivé
là-bas un goût extrême de la lecture
abruti de lecture disait les abbé et
dans un état chromatique donc la mère a
fini par venir le chercher
[Musique]
après tour c'est ici au château de
sachet à une vingtaine de kilomètres au
sud que nous allons poursuivre notre
exploration d'alsacienne le musée Balzac
est ici et la conservatrice de ce musée
Isabelle Lamy nous y attend
alors dites moi Isabelle Lamy comment ce
château de sachet entre dans la vie
d'Honoré de Balzac alors honoré Balzac à
connaissance du château de sachet en
faisant la connaissance des
propriétaires du château pendant son
enfance Jean et anne-margones était de
des personnes très fortunes des
départements que ses parents ont côtoyé
et Balzac à l'âge adulte lorsqu'il prend
l'habitude de revenir régulièrement en
Touraine va avoir pour point de chute
favoris le château de sachet
ici donc c'est la chambre d'Honoré de
Balzac quand il vient à Sacher et c'est
un lieu dont il faut parler les
symboliques pour lui ce lieu alors la
chambre de Balzac a Saché effectivement
c'est vraiment le Saint des Saints c'est
l'endroit où Balzac va se sentir le
mieux pour écrire et il a écrit ici le
manuscrit du père Goriot la première
partie d'illusion perdue il a corrigé
ses arbéraux tôle Louis Lambert une
dizaine d'oeuvres en tout ont été conçus
ici dans cette chambre de Balzac à
sachet
voilà donc là on a vraiment la vue sur
la vallée de l'Indre cette vallée qui a
inspiré par le Zac pour son roman le
lise dans la vallée et qui a été
transposée dans le roman d'une manière
totalement idéalisée et c'est vraiment
très symbolique de la façon dont Balzac
perçoit la tourelle dans son œuvre une
sorte d'Eden sur terre un paradis sur
terre dans lequel il fait bon vivre mais
aussi où il fait bon mourir comme c'est
le cas dans rillettes de morceaux dans
le lit dans la vallée mais également le
personnage de Lady Brandon dans la
nouvelle la Grenadière
[Musique]
Balzac mort en août 1850 à Paris dans
son appartement de la rue fortunée il
est crimelette victime d'une crise
cardiaque il est enterré au cimetière du
Père-Lachaise loin sans doute même trop
loin de sa Touraine natale